je suis extrêmement heureuse de vous
accueillir et de cet échange que nous
allons avoir autour de ce que nous
produisons ici en tant que parlementaire
il faut le reconnaître mais aussi autour
de ce que nous chassons la norme et je
pense qu'au delà de ce nettoyage que
nous faisons de manière ponctuelle
pertinentes et nécessaires
nous nous souhaitons vraiment participer
de manière collective à un changement de
culture autour de ce que j'appelle un
objectif que nous partageons qui est
celui de l'efficacité de l'action
publique et de la norme qui est utile
contre la norme qui est contre
productive parce qu'à un moment elle
bloque
elle bloque l'action publique et nous
savons que nous sommes autour de la
norme un certain nombre d'acteurs c'est
un peu comme une ruche autour de cette
affaire et qu'il convient que nous
échangions sur ce partage de la culture
que nous avons beaucoup de cette même
culture que nous avons beaucoup évoqué
avec le président lambert que nous
évoquons beaucoup avec notre collègue
qui le premier vice président rémy
pointereau puisque nous avons un
vice-président à la norme si je puis
dire ici dans cette délégation est que
nous avons aussi évoqué à madame avec
madame de montchalin que nous avons vu
récemment peut-être avant de démarrer à
la je dois vous préciser que cette
séquence qui dure jusqu'à 10 heures 50
voilà et films et que donc à certain
nombre de collègues sont avec nous
certains que nous voyons
particulièrement bien et d'autres qui
qu'ils nous entendent et je vous prie
d'excuser ceux qui ne sont pas là alors
peut-être juste avant nous avons parmi
nous un collègue sénateur d'avignon qui
va devoir nous quitter le tout à l'heure
en raison du drame qui sait
qui s'est produit hier et en solidarité
avec lui avec les policiers je vous
propose si vous êtes d'accord de
respecter
donc peut-être pour compléter eux la
philosophie de notre esprit que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure donc les
travaux que nous conduisons sur la norme
répondre répondre à une demande de du
présidente du sénat qui a spécifiquement
missionné notre délégation dans l'espoir
d'avancer sur ce terrain alors nos
efforts ne sont pas ménagés si je puis
dire et ils ont démarré il y a déjà un
certain temps et ils portent leurs
fruits puisqu'on aura l'occasion de
parler aussi de l'évaluation de l'action
publique
80% des dispositions que nous avions
porté par notre collègue rémy pointereau
dans une proposition de loi de
simplification du droit de l'urbanisme
ont été intégrés dans le champ du droit
de la même manière dans le pacte
national de revitalisation des
centres-villes repris dans la loi élan
par contre je lui disais je crois qu'il
reste un long chemin à faire et ce
chemin je pense qu'il est plutôt
culturels et qui conviendrait que
ensemble tous les acteurs que je citais
tout à l'heure nous procédions à une
sorte de changement de logiciel pour une
frugalité et une excellence normative
plutôt qu'une
une submersion parfois normative qui
vise l'efficacité de l'action publique
donc nous dans ce cadre nous mesurerons
parce que beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont été
élus locaux le rôle clé qui est tenu par
vaux par vos écoles qui sont
emblématiques de notre système de
sélection et d'excellence elle se situe
au coeur de la question de la
simplification carmon former ceux qui
écriront les normes les administrateurs
et les membres des deux cabinets ce qui
les mettront en heure avec plus ou moins
de capacité d'adaptation que la loi peut
donner ce qui les interpréteront
également dans les prétoires
avec plus ou moins de souplesse et
d'intelligence des réalités de terrain
donc il nous intéresse fortement de
savoir quelle place
occupe cette préoccupation dans la
pédagogie les contenus enseignés dans
vos écoles lors d'un récent e collègue
organisé par le président du cnn
monsieur gérard vous avez présenté des
évolutions de l'ena en matière de
logistique
peut-on dire aujourd'hui que tous les
élèves de l'ena comme ceux de les natifs
des modules de simplification
législative réglementaire et
administrative sous forme théorique et
d'études de cas en visant un objectif
qui doit être celui de ceux qui
contribuent de tous ceux qui contribuent
à l'action publique c'est l'efficacité
de l'action publique quel effet produit
la norme alors très récemment notre
délégation a organisé une consultation
nationale des élus que nous rendrons
public la semaine prochaine et cette
idée de renforcer la formation à la
simplification a reçu une très large
adhésion de la part de nos élus locaux
c'est même plus qu'une qu une large
adhésion
donc comment l'enjeu de simplification
et il appréhender des élus locaux
sont-ils sollicitée pour venir
concrètement expliqué les difficultés
rencontrées face à la fois au
foisonnement des normes leur complexité
mais aussi parfois leur contradiction
puisque les normes sont rattachés à des
thématiques quand l'élu doit régler un
problème général donc l'ena a mis en
place des stages en préfecture et en
entreprises c'est une excellente chose
les stages en territoire existe mais
nous nous avions une idée a suggéré que
le président de la république n'a pas du
tout évoqué dans son intervention du 8
avril dernier
de la convention managériale pourquoi ne
prévoit que je vends du mal à lire
pourquoi ne pas prévoir voir la
pardonnez moi une sortie d'école
systématique en collectivité ou en
administrations déconcentrées et or des
métropoles pour une durée limitée mais
suffisant de son côté la conférence des
présidents d'université a souligné
l'importance d'organiser la formation
allie s p sur une alternance touchant
tous les territoires de la république
dans leur diversité et pas seulement les
préfectures ou les chefs lieux où elles
sont implantées
s'agissant de l'ined le même principe
qui celui de développer une culture
commune des difficultés de terrain et
qui est une autre chose pourrait
s'appliquer au delà des stages
d'ouverture da d'une durée d'un mois
ne pourrait-on envisager un passage
obligé après sortie de l'école en tout
cas tôt dans la carrière au service de
l'état et enfin je voudrais évoquer la
formation continue puisque je crois que
la formation tout au long de la vie
professionnelle ainsi qu'on qu'on
appelle nous semble aujourd'hui être une
exigence compte tenu du rythme
d'évolution des choses de la complexité
et comment distinguer vous ces deux
volets quelles actions avez-vous dans ce
domaine en formation continue
enfin je crois que il ne s'agit pas pour
nous en tout cas d'opposer les
fonctionnaires de l'état et les grands
serviteurs de l'état qui sont je le dis
à titre personnel pour avoir été exercé
des fonctions d'élu local de très grande
qualité qui souvent accompagne les élus
pour trouver des solutions qui sont
facilitateur en interprétation de la
norme et qui parfois ont une efficacité
mais son coût qui est lié
je n'ose pas dire à la qualité de la
personne mais à cette sensibilité de
conséquence serviteur de l'état de
l'obligation de résultat à laquelle sont
condamnées
tous les élus locaux il nous semble que
parfois il y il y à ce que certains
d'entre nous appellent un manque de sens
concret ou en tout cas d'étude d'impact
de l'effet de la norme qui est produite
quel va être le résultat est ce que le
résultat de la norme va permettre
d'atteindre l'objectif d'efficacité de
l'action publique et un déficit de
culture du résultat qui est pour les
élus locaux une obligation donc comment
peut-on diffuser partager ce souci et
comment pouvons-nous et pouvez-vous
contribué à propager cette culture
professionnelle qui deviennent pour nous
comme ils ne se content de nature plutôt
qu une extravagance je vous remercie
je ne serai pas plus longue donc je
propose que chaque à nouveau
interviennent dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez et ensuite mes collègues ne
manqueront pas de deux questions je vous
remercie d'ores et déjà les collègues
qui souhaitent intervenir n'hésitez pas
à vous signaler
merci messieurs merci madame la
présidente je salue les sénateurs et
sénatrices ici présents et puis ceux qui
nous regardent par vision
je très heureux d'être ici d'abord se
faire quelques quelques remarques sur
lennar l'ena ne forment par an que 80
élèves donc on peut pas dire que tous
ceux qui fabriquent des normes ce pays
viennent de l'ema c'est une vraiment
très petite minorité et parmi ces 90 à
ceux qui seront effectivement mené à
fabriquer des normes et puis il ya ceux
qui étant dans les juridictions
administratives ou financières seront
menées allez allez juger ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya à peu près en france en
exercice 2010 narc sur 10000 haut
fonctionnaire il ya autant d ailleurs
d'énarques d'ingénieurs et beaucoup
d'ingénieurs me sont moore sont dans des
tâches administratives en particulier
dans un certain nombre de ministères où
ils sont sur des postes comme le poste
lettres les ans et helena et puis ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont fait ni
lennan les écoles d'ingénieurs qui sont
aussi aux fonctionnaires parce qu'ils
sont arrivés par des corps le débouché
par les corps universitaire ou
différemment ça c'est une remarque je
voulais faire s'agissant de la scolarité
à l'ena pour que vous dit que tout le
monde ait les idées à peu près clair sur
le sujet c'était scolarité elle dure un
peu moins de deux ans donc elle était si
rapide
la première année c'est un stage c'est à
dire qu'on envoie nos chronos 80 élèves
dans un stage du territoire
donc on l'a on l'appelle pas
volontairement préfecture mais
territoire pour qu'ils soient
sensibilisés aux questions du territoire
et à cette occasion mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs devaient sans
doute rencontrer nos stagiaires quand
ils sont dans vos départements ont dans
les critères que
[Musique]
on a pour les évaluer pendant ce stage
qui compte beaucoup à la fin dans le
classement de la scolarité il y à leur
efficacité your leur écoute du terrain
et il y a un certain nombre d'opérations
qu'on leur demande
je pense en particulier rencontre avec
les élus locaux les rencontre aussi avec
des jeunes élèves pour leur parler de
l'administration dans les lycées et
depuis l'année dernière j'ai supprimé le
stage entreprises que nos élèves avaient
l'habitude de faire dans des
départements affaires publiques des
grandes entreprises du cac40 pour la
remplacer par un stage de deux mois dans
une pme
donc les élèves de la promotion
2020-2021 comme ceux de la promotion
2021-2022 lire sur la promotion 2021
2022 sont à ce moment ci exactement mois
de mai et joie en pme pour qu'il prenne
aussi que conscience de ce que l'état
impose comme norme en petites et
moyennes entreprises qui vont souvent
pas du tout les moyens ni juridique et
financier a dit réussite et puis après
ils partent en stage international est
en deuxième année ils reviennent à
strasbourg pendant six mois et il ya des
scolarités se termine par ce qu'on
appelle les épreuves de classement et le
choix du code d'entrée et pendant ces
six mois ils ont un enseignement de
légistique c'est d'ailleurs une grande
nouveauté parce que les études
universitaires françaises y compris dans
les meilleures facultés de droit de se
plie ne prévoit pas de légistique on est
on vous apprend des règles de droit mais
on ne reprend pas comment on les
fabrique
donc on est très attentif sur ces
enseignements de logistique et depuis
que j'ai pris une direction de l'ena
depuis août 2010 est j'ai demandé que
l'on n'apprenne pas aux élèves seulement
à écrire des textes mais qu'on leur
apprenne à supprimer des textes et donc
qu'ils aient un réflexe plus ou moins un
et si possible les à -2 et donc ceci
ceci a commencé à se faire et on leur
apprend surtout à se poser d'abord la
question est il utile ou pas pour régler
des problèmes de recourir à la norme
je crois que c'est la première question
qui se pose
je me souviens qu'un sénateur c'était un
turbo loire la sarthe avait dit un jour
qui est décédé il ya quelques années on
m'avait dit un jour quand on n'a plus
d'argent on se paye de mots et je pense
et ça commençait pas répondre à une
question je ne connais pas d'argent eh
bien on crée de la norme et on me dit on
donne l'impression que on a réglé la
question
donc on leur demande de se poser à
chaque fois la question est-ce qu'il
faut vraiment une ombre s qui a pas
d'autre solution
est ce que quand on veut réduire la
vitesse il faut encore prendre des
normes aussi vaut mieux pas poser des
panneaux d'interdiction de limitation
d'interdiction de certaines voitures
il ya des choses comme ça on leur fait
rare d'ailleurs avec les élèves de
lynette des hackaton c'est à dire on
leur dit voilà il ya un problème
administratif
par exemple l'année dernière on a fait
travailler ses élèves sur le fait que
dans les petites entreprises
il y avait des contrôles exercés par
l'état ce qui est normal mais que ces
contrôles pour certaines entreprises se
succèdent à une telle vitesse que le
chef d'entreprise passé sa vie à rendre
compte au contrôle comment on peut faire
pour étaler les contrôles ou bien pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un contrôle
comporte plusieurs aspects et arrêtent
vallée est ennuyé tous les jours le chef
d'entreprise donc on essaye de leur
faire faire des exercices on fait aussi
ce qu'on appelle du design thinking se
dire comment on fait par exemple pour
éviter qu'ils étaient des files
d'attentes mais que je fais réfléchir
avec des spécialistes du design titre
assure la réorganisation des locaux
administratifs bref on essaye de le
remettre en tête que la norme n'est pas
la solution obligatoire à tous les pôles
faut dire que parfois ce sont les
autorités politiques qu'ils serviront
les ministres et le moment de faire un
nom
chacun sait bien que dans ce pays
quelles que soient les gouvernements dès
qu'il ya un problème on répond par un
texte et nos élèves devenus aux
fonctionnaires sont par définition
article 1 la constitution gouvernement
dispose ministre à sion aux ordres d'un
gouvernement qui va leur dire il ya eu
un sujet
répondez pas par un texte souvent nous a
d'ailleurs savez bien mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et donc ils font
ce qu'on leur demande mais on essaye de
dire de proposer aux autorités
politiques d'autre solution que les
textes
une fois qu'on a réglé le problème s'il
y a besoin du nord naturellement on va
leur demander de travailler sur cette
norme est ce qu'elle est de quel ordre
elle est ce qu'elle est constitutionnel
ce que législatives est ce qu'elle est
réglementaire on va leur demander donc
de ne trouver le niveau de la norme dans
suite de faire extrêmement attention à
la rédaction clarté du texte à
l'intelligibilité que me dit le conseil
professionnel
et puis on va surtout maintenant on leur
demande de plus en plus de ne pas
fabriquer un texte sans faire une étude
d'impact il était d'un pacs et les
études d'impact budgétaire économiques
sociaux environnementaux et on a rajouté
l'impact concret pour les usagers
autrement dit qu'est ce que ce texte y
faire et son application à ce qu'on
appelle le dernier kilomètre et ça on y
est extrêmement extrêmement sensible
donc tous ces sujets on essaye de les
enseigner c'est d'ailleurs une épreuve
l'épreuve de logistique qui aujourd'hui
compte beaucoup dans le classement de
sortie et qui fait à peu près 10%
manosque et c'était normal en gros les
stations 40% et les épreuves en 60 % et
donc les élèves y sont extrêmement
attentifs nous faisons en sorte que tous
ces sujets d'évaluation des politiques
publiques on travaille là-dessus avec
l'institut des politiques publiques
beaucoup de socialistes de l'évaluation
qui viennent soit beaucoup plus enseigné
qu'il ne l'était autrefois c'est à dire
qu'il ya l'impact et l'évaluation après
à quoi ça sert d'avoir pris un texte et
on s'aperçoit que ça ne sert à rien et
puis il ya un sujet sur lequel on essaie
de les développer
on a fait pour la conseiller cette année
parce que comme vous le disais tout à
l'heure madame la présidente le souvent
les administrations fabrique des nombres
en silo donc on a maintenant mis en
place des séances des 10 cas de
situations concrètes avec des cours
ou les séminaires plus exactement de
réunions interministérielles où chacun
vient et puis ils se rendent compte
qu'il ya des contradictions et ils
apprennent à régler les contradictions
enfin dernier point je terminerai par là
on leur demande de regarder ce qui se
fait à l'étranger
en tout cas dans nos principaux voisins
européens allemagne angleterre espagne
ou italie pour regarder comment on règle
le problème
je vous signale par exemple que d'un
petit pays qui les pays-bas ou pays-bas
par législature on a le droit de faire
qu'une seule loi sur un sujet c'est dire
si vous faites une loi sur le terrorisme
fait une loi par législature vous enfin
pas de une loi sur l'urbanisme mais pas
deux aux pays bas aux pays bas c'est
comme ça il y à il ya aussi des pays
dans lequel on arrive à faire en sorte
que la course à la norme s'arrête un
s'arrête un jour
donc ce n'est pas que la sphère des
administrations c'est aussi la sphère du
politique et ce qui est tout à fait
normal voilà madame le président ce que
je voulais vous lire en introduction
si beaucoup monsieur le directeur mais
comme je le disais nous n'accablons pas
plus que nous ne nous accable on parce
que nous savons que nous pouvons aussi
être producteur de normes c'est à dire
nous contribuerons à même si parfois il
nous est arrivé et je crois que c'est
pas du tout un reproche que moi j'allais
lso est là qui dans les territoires
quand ils sont prêts faits sont plutôt
de grande qualité nous aide à trouver
des solutions mais on a parfois des
interprétations dans une circulaire et
les décrets qui dévide l'esprit du
législateur et qui en tout cas parce que
cette démarche que vous évoquiez de
l'étude d'impact et de l'effet dans un
écosystème d'action n'est pas fait
conduit à une impossibilité d'agir
merci beaucoup monsieur gérard monsieur
périnet si vous voulez bien votre tour
merci madame la présidente et bonjour
madame vous et messieurs les sénateurs
cela trice donc lynette l'institut
national des études territoriales qui
est une des activités du centre national
de la fonction publique territoriale
l'établissement la maison commune des
collectivités territoriales pour la
formation de l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires territoriaux
quel que soit leur métier quels que
soient les collectivités dans lequel il
travaille est dans cet ensemble du cnfpt
line est situé à strasbourg voisine de
l'école nationale d'administration forme
et je voudrais insister
les administrateurs territoriaux les
conservateurs du patrimoine et les
conservateurs des bibliothèques et
depuis quatre ans le cadre d'emplois des
ingénieurs en chef et je le dis comme un
des éléments d'introduction servant mon
propos parce que cette
interdisciplinarité compte beaucoup dans
l'évolution de l'état d'esprit dans
l'altérité la proche des situations
complexes à lynette l'institut national
des études territoriales donc nous
formons ses élèves issus des concours
organisés par le cnfpt et ses élèves une
fois en poste après un an ou un an et
demi de formation et lynette ont
vocation à rejoindre les collectivités
territoriales auprès des élus locaux
région département grande
intercommunalité pour concevoir auprès
d'eux les les aider à concevoir le
projet porté par le mandat il concevoir
les politiques publiques l'action
publique est dirigée tout ou partie des
services de ces grandes collectivités
c'est la vocation première des élèves de
l'ined quand ils sortent
en fait ces élèves et ses hauts
fonctionnaires territoriaux ne sont pas
en eux-mêmes n'ont pas vocation à
eux-mêmes produire directement
évidemment la norme nationale en
revanche en interaction avec les
ministères en interaction avec nos
collègues de l'état ces élèves ou en
tout cas demain ces hauts fonctionnaires
ont une part dans le sujet ils sont en
revanche auprès des îles locaux dans
l'action au milieu de ces normes et donc
notre fil rouge c'est de les préparer à
l'action publique efficace et disons en
milieu complexe que ce soit en milieu
normatif social territorial politique et
parce que les enjeux que les
collectivités territoriales relève son
complexe de les dire de plus en plus
complexes oui parce qu'ils sont à la
croisée de beaucoup de deux sujets et
thématiques
donc évidemment la qualité de la norme
sa stabilité son économie compte dans
l'efficacité de l'action publique
la scolarité des élèves de lynette et à
quelques cas sinon particularité en tout
cas quelques constantes importante c'est
assez anciens comme modèle et c'est
d'abord une école d'application
c'est une école qui j'espère en tout cas
c'est ce que nous portons apprend à
faire agir et pour ce faire la formation
est essentiellement une formation
d'alternance la plupart du temps les
élèves sont sur le territoire sur le
terrain dans toutes les collectivités
territoriales qu'ils veulent bien les
accueillir et c'est vrai que je dois
dire que l'écosystème que nous formons
avec les collectivités territoriales et
est remarquable parce que ils sont
rapidement placé en situation dans les
collectivités territoriales et quand ils
reviennent à lynette à strasbourg dans
nos locaux
ils n'ont pas vraiment de cours
théoriques certains le regrettent
mais les acquis les fondamentaux
considéré comme étant pardon acquis et
on les les enseignements qu'ils sont
portés au sein dînette sont plutôt des
enseignements des retours d'expériences
partagées avec les élus locaux partagés
avec les pères leurs pairs pour mettre
en perspective ce qu'ils ont perçu
appris compris de leur passage sur le
terrain ne détaille pas les différentes
phases du passage sur le terrain mais
c'est bien une progressivité importante
dans leur stage les cours de leur stage
pardon les les élèves
sont invités à être au plus près des
problématiques très concrète des
collectivités locales patrick gérard
site est tout à l'heure le haka ton que
nous travaillons ensemble qui est en
fait à partir de leurs observations de
terrain
la résolution avec les élèves de l'ena
de problèmes très concrets souvent
d'ailleurs du parcours de l'usager et
taratata
voilà l'économie générale de la
formation à lynette et pour répondre à
ces directement à votre question de la
présence si vous le permettez ont-ils
des cours de légistes hic à presles t-il
à faire la norme
la réponse est non non je le dis
d'emblée parce que ils ne sont pas
comment ils n'ont pas d'enseignement qui
a comme qui aurait comme corpus le guide
de légistique la pause en guide de
légistique ils connaissent évidemment
leurs fondamentaux droit constitutionnel
en droit administratif etc
il pratique la rédaction d'actes
administratifs pour les collectivités
locales
délibération et autres mais ils n'ont
pas de d'entraînement à la rédaction des
textes réglementaires et législatifs que
vos assemblées porte pour autant ils
sont des utilisateurs auprès des élus de
ces textes là et c'est un des paramètres
de leurs actions de la capacité à agir
pour eux ce que je peux dire pour avoir
une note d'optimisme par rapport à ce
sujet c'est que on a pu voir évoluer
très sensiblement le positionnement des
hauts fonctionnaires territoriaux par
rapport à la norme
je prendrai l'exemple de la commande
publique il ya quelques années on a
peut-être une vingtaine d'années jeu
j'arrondis appris d'abord l'achat public
qui est une des actions les modalités
d'action essentielle des collectivités
locales par la norme et la contrainte
des délais par le et
le passage par les codes 2d marchés
publics étaient tous vécu comme une
contrainte mais l'achat se faisait par
le strict respect des procédures
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a évidemment
complètement intégré la réglementation
de l'achat public qui protège qui
garantit qui ouvre à la concurrence sans
en faire le lieu essentiel de nos à
notre action la qualité de l'achat je
pense a pu se développer
c'est un exemple dans le cadre de ce
code des marchés vu que ce que je veux
illustrer par là c'est que nous avons
une évolution de l'état d'esprit l'accès
au concours est essentiellement basée
sur une approche juridique la fonction
publique territoriale et y compris la
haute fonction publique a été vraiment
fort j'ai avec ledroit a pris à
l'utiliser aujourd'hui tout en le
respectant évidemment je pense qu'on a
réussi à déplacer le positionnement de
nos cadres non pas comme des simples
gardiens du des textes mais comme est en
capacité d'agir avec ce paramètre là et
en faire quelquefois des opportunités je
me permets de l'illustré ce cette
évolution qui je pense peut favoriser
comment dire l'appropriation par la
formation et le positionnement de la
fonction publique par rapport à la norme
je me permets de m'en tenir là ce stade
là si vous me permettez monsieur l'écart
vous évoquez le champ de la commande
publique qui est effectivement un champ
qui a pour objet comme action d'avoir
une finalité utile et qui parfois se
transforme en exercice de respect par
protection des précautions ce que nul ne
peut nier en un exercice
on va dire extrêmement procédurale et
que la norme parfois amène à prendre des
décisions qui sont un peu contre
productive titre est juste un petit
exemple en est ses paroles à mes
collègues il m'est arrivé
comme beaucoup de collègues dans le
cadre d'un marché
importants de construction le grand site
et d'une médiathèque d'avoir une
entreprise qui répondait avec laquelle
on avait déjà travaillé sur un autre
chantier savait était fort compliqué et
on aurait voulu l'éviter mais le marché
tel qu'il avait été organisée voilà
faisait qu'on n'a pas pu écarter cette
entreprise qui quand même un beau jeu ne
serait pas plus longue merci beaucoup
monsieur d donc j 3 demandes de parole
pour l'instant notre collègue jean
michel houle gars notre collègue laurent
burgoa et notre collègue philippe
dallier
je propose peut-être 2 3 qui champions
si vous êtes d'accord
voilà donc les uns et les autres se
préparent en effet vous permettra de
répondre merci jean michel tout à fait
merci madame la présidente merci à vous
messieurs les directeurs pour votre
premier éclairage donc je souhaitais que
complété par par un certain nombre de
questions d'abord peut-être une réaction
monsieur périnée vous avez tout à fait
raison je crois que le corpus normatif
est devenu un système complexe pour dire
à une certaines boîtes noires qui doit
se stabiliser autour de certains des
variants et le retour entre guillemets
al'approche des principes notamment pour
la commande publique me paraît moins
essentiels néanmoins il faut quand même
reconnaître que l'augmentation des
contentieux sur la forme fait que
souvent la forme l'emportent sur le fond
et dans cette approche
quand on regarde le monde de
l'entreprise on s'aperçoit que le mans
dans l'entreprise il est comme les
collectivités territoriales énormément
confronté à un certain nombre de normes
qui s'est elle aussi et vous aviez
raison monsieur gérard de de dire que
ces normes sont en silo je pense aux
référentiels qualité sûreté sécurité gis
a une santé au travail etc etc et on se
pose la question de l'interopérabilité
de ses normes donc est ce que vous vous
avez dans vos formations est ce que vous
avez un contact avec le monde de
l'entreprise pour voir comment le ce
monde dans l'entreprise arrive à gérer
cette interopérabilité
ça c'est ma première question et puis ma
deuxième question c'est autant le cnfpt
à travers sa délégation à la recherche
comme comment dirais-je l'ena avec la
chaire d'innovation public est ce que
vous êtes connecté entre guillemets le
monde de la recherche
parce que je dirais dans le sens des
sciences molles entre guillemets on a de
plus en plus recours nous produire des
systèmes experts je suis pas un fan de
l'intelligence artificielle et puis je
crois qu'il faudrait pas non plus des
possédés entre guillemets en essayant de
d'appuyer sur un bouton et puis dire
voilà quel est le mode de procédure mais
mais on voit que dans le monde de
l'entreprise on a de plus en plus entre
guillemets des procédures qui se tomatis
d'une certaine façon et qui arrive à
analyser l'interopérabilité des normes
est ce que ça existe dans le cadre de la
fonction publique
est ce que c'est le chat est ce que
c'est un champ de la recherche qui vous
paraît vous tout à fait intéressant qui
se serait aussi du bien de nous
expliquer justement quels sont les
travaux de recherche qui sont menés dans
ce dans ces domaines quelle parole à
notre collègue leur zone de robin merci
madame la présidente
moi je voudrais bien plutôt poser une
question monsieur le directeur de l'ena
tout d'abord une remarque prestation vos
stagiaires sont de grande qualité comme
tous les allemands dans les préfectures
prennent à tester régulièrement par
exemple la stagiaire actuelle qui a
préfecture du gard sur clip tout
particulièrement du contrat rural c'est
à nous écouter d'être content et je peux
lui dire et je lui ai déjà dit
et je peux vous dire que la sous préfète
qui est en charge de social est ravi
d'avoir sa présence à ses côtés pour
suivre ce dossier complexe avec les élus
locaux etc
elle a déjà fait part que dans quelques
mois malheureusement le kit aura prouvé
que tueur du gard et la sous-préfète ce
devant le bar qui l'a remplacé alors je
voudrais voir votre papa votre point de
vue personnel parce que vous avez un
droit de réserve sur le directeur par
rapport à la décision du président de la
république de fermer l'école nationale
de l'ena mais savoir comment ça se
passait parce que j'ai bien compris il y
aura une tranche commun par rapport aux
au futur et cette étude du service
public
est ce que vous nous expliquer comment
les futurs élèves vont pouvoir être
affecté je conviens 3 en commun avec
diverses écoles lennar et cette étude
des hautes études en santé publique de
l'escwa nous expliquer comment ça risque
de se passer sur 20 et puis vous dire
que à titre personnel c'est vrai corps
c'est facile pour nous élus de critiquer
c'est à dire les énarques
mais je crois que nous les élus je crois
qu'on est favorable aussi à se connait
une élite dans ce domaine de la comme
dans d'autres domaines que ça fait la
fierté de la france et que des fois
c'est facile de critiquer mais on a bien
besoin de cette élite par rapport à
d'autres pays
chers collègues il a parlé de notre
collègue philippe dallier qui est en
visio chercher les bidons vous
m'entendez oui très bien si on cherche
effectivement à comprendre et à lutter
contre cet excédent en mieux dans votre
pays ou bien sûr regarder du côté du
parlement je pense que là de notre côté
il ya des choses à faire
un problème une loi un problème une loi
reste quand même une tendance assez
lourde alors je ne sais pas si on
arrivera un jour un système tel qu'il
existe aux pays-bas avec une seule loi
sur un sujet donné par législature c'est
peut-être un peu trop contraignant mais
il ya du boulot à faire coter parlement
c'est une certitude après côté
administration
là aussi il ya des choses à regarder et
mais est-ce que parmi les sujets qu'il
faudrait prendre en compte est ce que la
culture du parapluie ceinture bretelles
n'est pas un véritable problème
je fais référence à la à la
judiciarisation de la société c'est vrai
que on essaye tous à la fois côté élus
et côté administration d'essayer de
limiter les risques pour ceux qui
prennent des décisions mais est-ce qu'au
bout du compte tout ça ne nous conduit
pas à un excellent de nord alors en
ayant dit cela je n'ai pas la solution
et mais je pense en tous les cas que ce
soit du côté de la préparation des hauts
fonctionnaires comme du côté des
parlementaires
il y a à réfléchir sur le sujet voilà
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans ce
domaine là si chers collègues donc je
vous propose messieurs les directeurs de
de répondre à cette série de ses
premières séries qui sauf si vous voulez
bien et ensuite nous avons eu notre
prise de parole de notre collègue sonia
de la provôté dominique estrosi sassone
michel et michel gré aux messieurs les
directeurs bien merci madame la
présidente je voudrais d abord aux
sénateurs houlgate que naturellement
nous mettons mes rencontres avec les
entreprises dans nos enseignements pas
seulement dans le stage en pme mais un
certain nombre de chefs d'entreprise ont
l'occasion de devenir et de s'exprimer
devant nos élèves comme nos élèves
rencontre à strasbourg les élus locaux
pas seulement le président de région de
présidents des collectivités européennes
d'alsace la maire de strasbourg où
d'autres mais aussi quelquefois des
maires de toutes petites communes
flores alsacien des vosges je me
souviens d'une rencontre avec l'un d'eux
il ya quelques il ya deux ans donc on y
fait très attention
naturellement les entreprises sont on
l'a dit sur les pme on l'a dit on le
fait avec un ensemble d'exercices
pratiques fut pourrait vous donner au
coeur de la réflexion de simplification
c'est qu'on sait très bien que c'est des
entreprises qui créent des emplois et
que si on les bloque par des normes on
n'y arrivera jamais alors le sénateur
houlgate poser la question de du monde
de la recherche
lena est membre partenaire de psl paris
sciences et lettres qui regroupe l'école
normale supérieure l'école des mines
l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales école de chimie paris l'inria
qui est très important en matière
d'intelligence artificielle et l'école
normale supérieure mais je crois que je
n'ai je les cite
donc nous travaillons avec le monde de
la recherche
nous avons d'ailleurs l'idée que à terme
un jour il faudra que les énarques
puisse être docteur parce que c'est un
autre problème
sur 1 122 postes au niveau international
il s'agit du fmi de labeur de l' ocde
etc
les
les organisations internationales
recherche des personnes qui sont
docteurs et donc qu'ils ont l'habitude
de douter ce qui est ce qu'il est c'est
aussi bien quelquefois dans
l'administration de réitérer son nom de
l'exercice bref cette démarche de la
recherche on va on essaie de travailler
que le psn dans l'optique de toi on la
travaille aussi par des conférences
scientifiques qui ont été institués à
l'ena ya trois ans par le prix nobel et
on en a le plaisir à strasbourg 5
ils viennent devant nos élèves pour leur
parler d'un certain nombre de sujets
qu'ils s'agissent des problèmes de
molécules d'intelligence raphia parfois
les faire réfléchir il bréchet sur les
affaires de l'énergie atomique
et depuis cette année j'ai fait
travailler nos élèves sur des commandes
que font les administrations à nos
élèves de travailler sur un ensemble de
sujets en collaboration avec les agents
du corps des mines de sorte que les deux
cultures soit se confrontent et nos
élèves voit très bien que les ingénieurs
ont des souvent des façons de répondre
plus pratique et moins normatif que les
administrateurs nous je pense que tout
ça a été tu dises aux sénateurs burgaud
âge dont je remercie ces éloges et sur
l'ena et sur l'élite et sur ses
stagiaires
lena doit être transformé en sp au 1er
janvier 2022
vous savez que le l'ordonance doit en
principe passer au conseil mise du 26
mai elle devra être ensuite évidemment
ratifiée par l'assemblée nationale il
par le sénat la différence entre l'ena
il y espère c'est que lyès pc lena - des
choses et plus des choses selena en gros
- l'accès aux grands corps à la sortie
il n'y aura plus d'accès ou encore à la
sortie de li sp lés donc plus d'accès
direct au conseil d'état la cour des
comptes inspection des finances mission
de la sphère sociale de l'inspection
générale admistration
mais tout le monde n'entrera dans un
corps qui s'appelle corps des
administrateurs de l'état qui sera un
nouveau corps qui succédera encore
l'administrateur civil
ça c'est la différence avec les nerfs à
aux actus aux activités habituelles line
s'ajouteront deux autres types
d'activités premièrement le tronc commun
dont vous avez parlé qui est destiné à
faire que de 14 écoles de service public
dont lynette l'école des hautes études
en santé publique à l'école de la
magistrature l'écho les commissaires de
police et que les officiers de
gendarmerie l'école des mines pour le
corps d'amy et pour que les élèves de
ces écoles est une culture commune sur
les questions de science de science de
pauvreté de déontologie de sens de
l'état par exemple est donc cet aspect
aura la responsabilité de proposer cette
formation commune à toutes les tous les
élèves de toutes ces écoles et puis
troisième responsabilité lit sp devra
développer plus que ne fait encore l'ena
la formation continue et notamment créer
ce qu'on appelle entre guillemets une
école de guerre sur le modèle de l'école
de guerre militaire c'est une école il
se fera plus tard huit ou dix ans en
douze ans après avoir quitté l'ump mais
pour toutes les écoles et qui formera
aux fonctions très supérieurs préfets
ambassadeurs recteurs directeurs de
l'administrer les tâches que devraient
faire les sp à partir du 1er janvier
2022 au sénateur d'allier il a raison de
dire que quelquefois cc ceinture et
bretelles c'est vrai que la norme est
est une répond au principe de précaution
en s'assurant contre d'éventuelles
poursuites judiciaires
et que la judiciarisation de notre
système de tous les responsables publics
locaux comme fonctionnaire ou un
ministre est telle que quelquefois on
encadre trop les textes parce qu' on se
dit
on sera dans les clous si jamais
quelqu'un nous poursuit ce qui fait que
ça donne beaucoup moins de liberté
l'appréciation qu'on devrait avoir des
textes plus généraux laissant plus
d'appréciation à ceux et celles qui sont
chargés de les appliquer et que sans
doute cette judiciarisation à cette
conséquence même si elle a évidemment
l'avantagé heureux d'essayer d'être
vertueux mais quelquefois à force de
vouloir être trop vertueux on devient
trop peureux merci à la présidente sur
la première question relative à
passerelles entre la recherche et la
formation à lynette notamment nous en
avons il ya des passerelles avec par
exemple le graal
le groupement de recherche pour et avec
lequel nous développons un prix de thèse
par exemple qui nous permet de soutenir
des travaux ce qui nous permet de mettre
en perspective certains sujets ou encore
avec l'université bientôt de montpellier
pour le cycle supérieur de management
qui est diplômant et qui est dispensée à
linars plutôt en formation continue
mais il ya des passerelles ou encore des
partenariats plus ponctuelles avec par
exemple la chaire de l'action publique
et territoire dans quelque temps où on
va travailler sur l'organisation et
l'évolution l'organisation des
collectivités locales donc c'est un sont
des passerelles qui existent ils ce sont
des passerelles qui je pense peut être
développer davantage pour qu'elles
s'imprègnent davantage le cours de la
formation notamment des élèves pour leur
donner un peu de champ de et de
connexions avec des perspectives et 10
ont un effet miroir sur l'action en
cours
c'est une formation qui est très
concentré sur la capacité d'agir
la capite d'action il faut pas qu'on se
départisse de la capacité de
de saisir les lignes de force de la
recherche pour avoir un retour utile
alors on le fait régulièrement dans
différents partenariats ponctuels c'est
certain sur le rapport aux entreprises
privées il est plus modeste que ce que
vient d'évoquer patrick gérard directeur
de l'ena je le dis parce que les stages
d'ouverture permettent aux élèves de
d'aller en fait à peu près où ils
veulent et beaucoup vont dans des
secteurs associatif beaucoup vont aussi
dans les services de l'état quel qu'il
soit en juridiction et certains
rejoignent les entreprises peut-être pas
assez peut-être pas assez mais et puis
nous pouvons accueillir
évidemment il n'y a pas de limite à cela
des intervenantes viennent du secteur
privé fin lynette a comme vocation
d'être cette école d'application avec
l'ambition d'être la plus ouverte
possible à tout l'écosystème qui fait la
réalité de l'action locale et il n'y a
évidemment aucune limite à cela
l'important c'est que les élèves
puissent saisir l'intégralité des
acteurs qui font un territoire et leurs
contraintes ou leurs aspirations sur le
tronc commun jeu permettrait de ne pas
compléter les propos de patrick gérard
puisque lynette va participer au tronc
commun nous rédigions actuellement avec
les écoles les attendus de ce tronc
commun et l'intégreront en 2022 dans la
formation de nos élèves administrateurs
jeudi administrateurs puisque tout à
l'heure j'ai j'ai cité les conservateurs
de bibliothèques les conservateurs du
patrimoine et les ingénieurs en chef qui
malheureusement n'ont pas été
appréhendés dans ce cercle là et qui
auraient pu bénéficier tout autant de
cette évolution
sur le dernier point je voulais dire
peut-être tout à l'heure sur l'état
d'esprit et l'état d'esprit ceinture et
bretelles j'évoquais tout à l'heure le
l'évolution de l'état d'esprit par
rapport à l'exemple de la commande
publique et au fait qu'on s'est déplacé
peut-être de du carcan de la norme la
qualité de l'achat pour faire très court
en tout cas c'est une ambition
je pense que
on porte une attention très importante
et en espérant qu'elles soient
fructueuses dans les collectivités à
l'esprit de responsabilité
les îles locaux vous me demandiez tout à
l'heure madame la présidente s'il venait
à l'ined pour nous interpeller un peu
pour nous dire ce qu'ils attendent des
fonctionnaires territoriaux ou ils
viennent à lynette et ils disent les
attendus à l'égard des élèves aider la
future haute fonction publique
territoriale attendu d'exemplarité
mais aussi de capacité d'agir et de ne
pas recréer de la procédure et de la
norme là où il y en a déjà
parce que si nos élèves et nos
fonctionnaires n'ont pas vocation à
rédiger des normes nationales
ils peuvent avoir quelquefois une
inclinaison à rédiger des normes locales
qui viennent s'interposer entre l'usagé
l'habitant et la norme nationale et donc
l'état d'esprit qu'on essaie de leur
inculquer c'est celui d'aller aux jeux
le plus directement vers l'habitant est
d'usagé et de ne pas compliquer par des
procédures qui s'impose à nous mêmes par
ailleurs les normes actuelles et ce à un
esprit un développement l'esprit de
responsabilité
les fonctionnaires territoriaux doivent
préserver les élus et leurs
collectivités des risques qu'ils
encourent assurément ils doivent être
attentifs à cela c'est un rôle
fondamental dont on ne peut pas se
départir
cela étant la mesure du risque fait
partie des compétences que nous devons
développer
il y à risque et risque il ya des
risques de plusieurs natures il y a
quelques fois de l'incertitude et
s'attire cette incertitude pardon ne
doit pas bénéficier à la rédaction de
normes qui vient nous rassurer sans agir
mais plutôt à l'action sans normes
beaucoup monsieur le directeur les les
collègues houlgate et d'alliés ont
évoqué ce qui est je crois parfois un
mal français l'inscription ça les
personnes que j'aime et l'inscription
dans la constitution d'un principe de
précaution me semble ne pas avoir fait
l'objet d'étude d'impact
il me semble avoir des effets très
difficile et vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire que le fonctionnaire doit
sécuriser et protéger les lui qui a
décidé mais que l'élu doit aussi prendre
son champ de responsabilité et que
j'apprécie ce que vous dites l'un et
l'autre au sens où tout en appliquant
principe de précaution et donc de
sécurité il convient au préalable de
mesurer l'occurrence du risque et sa
gravité et que je sais que parfois y
compris nous législateurs nous avons
sous le fait de l'émotion ou que sais-je
parfois une occasion si je puis dire de
légiférer à partir de ce qui est sans
doute très grave mais ce qui est un
épiphénomène en occurrence et en gravité
la vie est en elle même on va dire pavé
de 2,2 de risque comment cet équilibre à
trouver et le mot que vous évoquez de
responsabilité importants il ya quelques
temps au titre de la délégation j'ai
écrit j'adresse un courrier au premier
ministre lui demandant ce qu'il en était
de l'invitation qu'il avait dû faire aux
préfets d'appliquer leur pouvoir dayraut
gatif aux normes c'est un avoir une
intelligence d'appréciation je pense que
le recensement doit être en train d'être
fait car je n'ai pas de réponse donc
j'aurais tendance à penser que
l'utilisation du pouvoir dérogatoire a
été maximale parce que on met beaucoup
de temps à nous répondre
mais nous serons au bout d'un an je
passe tous types de la parole à mes
collègues sonia de la provôté qui est en
visio dominique estrosi sassone qui est
en présentiel ainsi que michel gréaume
chère sonia meersman amena presbourg
merci pour pour ses enseignements riche
sur vos écrans les grandes écoles
respectives qui
le précise ici également à l'instar de
luis collègues faut aussi notre fierté
nous avez besoin nous avons besoin d'une
fuite de deux têtes particulièrement
bien formés pour pouvoir nous
accompagner dans les politiques
publiques
moi je vais poser deux questions qui
rosit rejoindre un peu celle de mes
collègues
la première sur sur cette question de
deux de la hiérarchie des grands corps
qui s'est transformé en priorité des
actions publiques quelque part cette
question de la prééminence du budgétaire
la question du du du principe de
précaution qui est un élément très
présent dans l'application sur le
terrain de la part de de
l'administration et puis cette espèce de
discours qu'on entend que certaines
grandes administrations haute
administration serait pas tout à fait
privilégiée en tout cas par les
meilleurs des promotions et je pense par
exemple à l'administration sanitaire je
n'ai pas vérifié l'information mais
c'est c'est un peu ce qu'il se dit et
quelque part est ce que est ce que cette
façon de fonctionner n'a pas finalement
creusé l'écart avec le terrain le
ressenti par les citoyens les élus
locaux dans un pays quand même hyper
centralisé où le pouvoir local a du mal
à apporter sa voix est il à faire bouger
les choses étant évidemment est attendu
que sur le terrain les priorités ne sont
pas forcément les priorités budgétaires
et le principe de précaution
systématique mais plutôt une forme de
souplesse d'efficacité l'action sociale
la prise en charge sanitaire et donc
quelque part s conseiller à tout cela
finalement entre le fonctionnement au
national l'organisation nationale des
priorités nationales et celles du
terrain n'ont pas été source de ce grand
malentendu entre notre haute
administration ou et et c'était pourtant
bien formés et la façon dont on
fonctionne il est ce que la difficulté
devient pas aussi du fait que finalement
l'équilibrage entre pouvoir central et
le pouvoir local aurait certainement
permis en aller retour
plus prises en compte dans la façon dont
les uns et les autres
orienter leur poussent leurs pensées les
work leur action est mon deuxième que ma
deuxième réflexion part sur une usure
salissent de la loi la règle à nord qui
est entre complètement en difficulté ou
en groupe excité avec le paradoxe
français qui est justement que notre
pays n'est fait que de différences et
notamment de différences territoriales
et comment vous voyez par la suite la
façon de former les uns et les autres
pour que ces différences territoriales
entraîne dans la loi la règle écrite ou
proposer le fait qu'elle puisse
s'adapter et qu'elle tienne compte
justement de ce qui pourrait être vécues
comme des anomalies qui en réalité est
ma vraie vie sur le tient je vous
remercie
je passe la parole à notre collègue
dominique mercy beaucoup madame la
présidente bonjour messieurs les
directeurs
moi je vais vous poser une question qui
est beaucoup plus générale dont on
entend régulièrement parler l'écossé
qu'on a beaucoup mis en avant depuis
quelques années l'absence
d'hétérogénéité des élites françaises
issues des grandes écoles en france et
particulièrement de l'ena il est vrai
que la plupart des élèves d'origine
modeste
parmi les étudiants des grandes écoles
est passée de 29%
grosso modo en 1950 à 9 % de nos jours
alors la ségrégation sociale bien
évidemment j'en ai conscience
elle ne qu elle commence bien avant
l'accès aux grandes écoles
comment se voir dès le collège voire
même malheureusement la primaire mais
cette quasi homogénéité des élites
françaises
est-ce qu'elle pourrait pas forcément
expliqué aussi pourquoi aucune
originalité d' approche est possible et
pensez vous que aujourd'hui le
changement de sigle de l'ena ali s p va
pouvoir quelque peu inversée cette
situation merci co
cher dominique la parole est à notre
collègue michel gréaume sénatrice du
nord
merci madame la présidente merci
messieurs les directeurs pour vos
explications sur vos établissements
ma question porte sur le fait qu'ils
aient parfois plus facile de trouver les
normes a supprimé ou modifié
j'étais très contente que vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure en discutant avec des
maires ruraux qu'avec des maires de
communes aux autres collectivités de
plus grand de strates
en effet j'ai pu me rendre compte que
les services ne faut pas remonter
forcément les possibilités de
modification ou de suppression de
certaines normes peut-être afin de se
protéger juridiquement certains services
explique sans faire remonter les
applique les lois sans faire remonter
les incohérences je vous donner un petit
exemple simple par exemple droit civil
et le droit d'urbanisme qui l'un
autorise une ouverture dans la cour du
voisin et l'autre ne l'autorisent pas
c'est tout simple c'est pas compliqué
cela au présidium souvent des recours
malheureusement au conciliateur dans les
communes comment faire pour justement
ces problèmes de normes puisse remonter
aux fonctionnaires et de quelle façon du
mois et la suites qui pourraient être
données à ces remontées et de quelle
façon
parce que dans une petite commune le
maire est au courant de tout parce que
il est directement associé au problème
du dossier
camer d'une plus grande strats et les
services et les services ne faut pas
remonter forcément voilà merci merci
beaucoup et sur les directeurs c'est à
vous maintenant la présidente constate
que les questions sont posées selon les
règles la parité 3 center 3 sénatrice
bien je vais répondre volontiers je
n'étais pas bien
d'abord pour répondre à madame delà de
la provôté il y a à la sortie de l'ena
depuis 1945 c'était une volonté du
général de gaulle il faut pas oublier
que l'ema a été créée parce que avant
chaque corps et chaque ministère
recrutait individuellement
le conseil d'état a recruté ses membres
la cour des comptes recommande à ceux
l'ayant des finances le ministère de
l'intérieur recrutait lui-même les
préfets me sers d'agriculture à tarascon
et chacun s'était aperçu que ces
recrutements organisé par chacun des
corps ou des ministères donné lieu en
réalité de la cooptation que lorsqu'on
était fils frères cousins parce qu'à
l'époque il n'y avait que les hommes qui
pouvaient être candidats de quelqu'un
qui était en place on avait toutes les
chances de réussir et toutes ces
réflexions ont été faites aussi bien par
jean zay que par marc l'historien marc
bloch qui a expliqué que si on 40 tout
s'était effondré c'est aussi parce qu'on
avait d'administration qui n'avait pas
été capable de tenir donc le général de
gaulle a souhaité que tous les corps de
la haute fonction publique soient
recrutés de la même façon c'est-à-dire
entrée par le même concours formation
commune est sorti à ce moment là en
fonction du classement de sortie et non
pas des relations personnelles on
demandait au premier puis au 2e essai
draps de choisir son corps ou son os sur
ministère et ce système prévaut jusqu'à
la promotion qui va terminer sans sa
scolarité en 2022
après comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
ils seront tous
administrateur de l'état et ils ne
pourront aller dans les grands corps que
plus tard au minimum deux ans après un
ayant eu une expérience de deux terrains
alors voilà on approfondit me disait il
y a des je sais qu'il ya un bruit qui
court 10 ans chez les élèves les moins
bien classés vont au ministère de la
santé c'est d'abord c'est complètement
inexacte
je rappelle d'ailleurs que fois un élève
qui entre à l'ena quel que soit son
classement quelquefois qui est 0,5 point
je veux voir on peut pas dire que c'est
un mauvais élève parce qu'il est il est
classé dans les derniers l'ena il est
entré il n'est pas entré par effraction
il a mérité une scolarité qui a été
réussie et puis à la fin il ya un
classement
nous avons en réalité très peu de postes
au ministère de la santé pour la bonne
raison que l'administration du secteur
de la santé avec la division en france
des trois fonctions publiques fonction
publique d'état fonction publique locale
et fonction publique hospitalière
elle est principalement détenue par des
administrateurs forme et directeurs
d'hôpitaux autres par l'école des hautes
études en santé publique de rennes donc
il y assez peu d'énarques commissaire
santé cette année le gouvernement a
demandé que pour la promotion sortante
qui va sortir le 15 octobre il y ait
plus de postes au ministère de la santé
et donc il y en aura il y en aura
davantage sur la question sur les
besoins de loi fin la fabrication des
lois et son
le problème de la différenciation
territoriales évidemment il faut
permettre d'avancer sa territoriales
mais on a toujours un problème dans ce
pays on se trouve que j'étais aussi mère
donc j'ai maire de vincennes pendant six
ans je connais un peu ça on a quand même
aussi dans ce pays une obsession
d'égalité qui fait que à chaque fois
qu'on veut faire différenciation les
gens denis de madrid pourquoi lui fait
comme ça et pas comme ça on a toujours
ce sujet la différence mais le principe
d'égalité absolue et donc ça c'est un
principe que seuls les politiques
peuvent résoudre c'est par
l'administration de de dire comment
comment il faut le faire à la sénatrice
estrosi sassone l'absence de l'absence
de diversité dans les dents les élites
françaises
c'est vrai qu'il y à 50 ou 60 ans il y
avait sans doute plus de diversité dans
les élites françaises
mais on arrive à quelque chose il est
tout à fait paradoxal c'est que plus on
m'a élevé le niveau éducatif et plus le
maximum un plus grand nombre d'élèves
sont arrivés au baccalauréat puis aux
études supérieures plus paradoxalement
la ségrégation sociale s'est renforcée
c'est à dire que nous avons aujourd'hui
malgré tout à l'ena comme elin est plus
d'élèves venant de milieux favorisés que
de milieux défavorisés en face que
concerne l'ena moi j'ai dans la
promotion actuelle j'ai 38 % des élèves
qui étaient boursiers l'enseignement
supérieur très peu de grandes écoles
notamment dans le domaine scientifique
ou commerciales ont ces chiffres là
c'est en général 4 à 10 fois plus bas
donc et si nous arrivons à avoir autant
de boursiers dans ces mots spurs et
grâce notamment au concours interne qui
permet de la promotion de fonctionnaires
au troisième concours qui permet à des
gens en tenue du secteur privé ou
associatif ou électif venir d'entrée
alors est ce que est ce qu'on peut on
peut encore progresser vous savez que le
gouvernement a décidé à la demande du
président de république de lancer cette
année un concours supplémentaires dans
un certain nombre d'écoles dont lynette
et les notes on appelle le concours
talent enfin le nom c'est deuxième
concours externe ce moment c'est à peu
près la même chose j'ai réservé à des
étudiants qui étaient boursiers de
l'enseignement supérieur et qui ont fait
des préparation dans un certain nombre
d'écoles ou d'instituts qui les prépare
à cela nous espérons que ça ne t'y vas
cela va permettre d'avoir une plus
grande diversité sociale et pour moi à
côté la diversité sociale il ya deux
autres diversité qu'on oublie parfois
qui sont extrêmement importante c'est la
diversité culturelle ne faut pas qu'ils
pensent tous la même chose qu'ils aient
fait tout les mêmes études c'est
pourquoi il ya deux ans j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de créer un concours pour
les docteurs et nous avons l'année
dernière admis pour la première fois des
docteurs en sciences dures informatique
mathématiques physique l'aisne cette
année des docteurs en sciences humaines
et sociales l'année prochaine des
docteurs en sciences de la vie pour
qu'ils aient des cultures différentes et
que les élèves ne soient pas tous sur un
modèle de pensée juridique économique ou
financière et puis à la diversité
territoriale et
la vérité c'est que on a plus de la
moitié de nos élèves qui ont fait des
études supérieures à paris et moins les
autres évidemment qui nous fait sur le
résultat victoire est très peu hélas
venez en outre-mer aussi c'est un vrai
sujet donc on est dehors j'ai passé par
exemple un accord avec le gouvernement
de nouvelle calédonie pour une formation
pour que des élèves de nouvelle
calédonie viennent dans nos classes
préparatoires égalité des chances qu'ils
vont s'appeler talent préparer les
concours de l'ena ou de du reste des
autres haute fonction publique
on est en train de regarder ça avec la
guyane et puis si on peut faire plus on
fera plus mais je pense que ces trois
aspects diversité sociale diversité
culturelle et la diversité territoriale
à madame le sénateur gréaume qui
m'appelle l'attention sur les sur la
nécessité de consulter des maires ruraux
quand nos élèves sont stagiaires avec
eux des sous-préfets sont en vacances ou
le sont en période de remplacement entre
deux sous préfet on en voit souvent nos
élèves dans les sous-préfectures va
faire l'intérim et on leur demanda c'est
à ce moment là d'être davantage d'en
profiter pour être davantage attentifs
aux maires des petites communes je sais
que beaucoup le font avec plaisir quant
aux quant au droit civil un clip
proclame le droit de propriété et le
droit d'urbanisme qui par définition
limité au nom de
l'intérêt de la collectivité locale il
ya toujours des contradictions entre
tous les droits et là aussi c'est aux
autorités politiques pour moi de décider
mais j'ai toujours mais toujours ça il
faut que l'administration n'est pas là
pour faire le travail du politique c'est
aux politiques de décider et
l'administration est là pour faire le
travail dans le cadre de ce que lui dit
le politique de pour lui faire des
propositions intelligentes si possible
sans risque juridique mais c'est cette
politique qui décide c'est pas la
laisser pas l'administration
merci à notre exemple sur la première
question peut être de la hiérarchie des
des grands corps je dirais que en ce qui
concerne les élèves de lynette et leur
sortie on nous ne sommes pas sur le même
modèle et mais ça me permet un peu par
analogie de l'expliquer un petit peu ce
modèle de lynette et les évolutions
qu'on peut constater sur ce sujet qui a
connu même registre
d'abord quand les élèves de l'ined sorte
de lynette ils ne sont pas affectés ils
ne sont pas classés et il porte un
projet professionnel
une envie qui dépend de beaucoup de
paramètres dont ce qu'ils auront
découvert compris en formation et c'est
la rencontre avec le projet d'une équipe
d'élus et un exécutif dans les
territoires c'est ainsi qu'ils sont
recrutés ce qui permet à la fois
l'absence de classement
un travail sincèrement collectif durant
la scolarité et un champ plus ouvert en
tout cas - normes et à la sortie de
l'école et un autre point qui est
important c'est de l'évolution que l'on
a pu constater il ya quelques années les
élèves de lynette par tuer les
administrateurs territoriaux voulait
être parent soit directrice ou directeur
général des services c'est plus simple
soit directeur des finances ou directeur
des ressources humaines et je m'en étais
étonné il ya longtemps déjà auprès d'eux
et aujourd'hui tous les champs des
politiques publiques de toutes les
collectivités locales je prends le
risque de dire ainsi sont occupés par
ces élèves qui sortent de lynette la
protection de l'enfance l'insertion les
infrastructures enfin je perds
l'éducation le sport la culture sont
aujourd'hui investis avec passion
souvent et engagement par ces hauts
fonctionnaires territoriaux
je pense que c'est une belle évolution
qui a dit que nous n'avons pas cette
hiérarchie décor où cette hiérarchie
dans l'emploi un élément de comparaison
et et d'évolution quant à cette
éventualité rares chi décor tu peux
empêcher l'action sur la question de
l'università l'universalité de la norme
évidemment quand on travaille dans
différentes collectivités dans
différents territoires on voit que les
normes ne sont pas forcément adaptées à
telle ou telle situation où je veux dire
même géographique ou sociale
donc oui tout ce qui permettra
d'améliorer la capacité que nous aurons
à différencier la norme l'adapter de
manière concrète pour un territoire je
pense facilitera l'action et servira est
en fait la décentralisation c'est à dire
la capacité des élus locaux à porter un
projet sur un territoire donné
l'égalité quelquefois quand on part donc
quand on constate quelques fois qu'on on
peut s'écarter de l'égalité au sens où
tous les habitants des quatre coins de
la france
ne se voit pas tout à fait appliquer la
même norme on s'en étonne et 1d réflexe
est de pouvoir recentraliser comme si la
recentralisation régler le problème de
l'uniformité
il n'y a pas plus de risques dans
l'illégalité dans la décentralisation
qu'il y en a dans la centralisation
c'est peut-être une vue de l'esprit sur
l'absence d'hétérogénéité des des élèves
de lynette
nous partageons vraiment et sincèrement
l'enjeu qui reste une plus grande
diversité sociale d'une plus grande
diversité géographique comme l'a dit
monsieur gérard il ya quelques instants
pour le cnfpt inde et des moyens
d'améliorer cette diversité sociale
c'est aussi le continuum qui lie à entre
lynette la formation à lynette et
l'information dans l'ensemble de la
fonction publique territoriale
d'où mon insistance dans l'introduction
à bien attacher à bien considérer qu'ils
n'étaient n'est qu'un des éléments de
l'activité du cnfpt est que notre action
doit s'inscrire comme un continuum
permettant à celles et ceux
fonctionnaires territoriaux dans les
plus petites communes mais de pouvoir
accéder à ce concours d'ingénieur en
chef de conservateurs ou
d'administrateurs pour et bien selon
leurs envies ou leurs capacités occupé
des fonctions plus importantes s'il le
souhaite ce continuum permet d'améliorer
la diversité mais c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes engagés dans
les classes préparatoires talent à
nantes et à strasbourg
avec léna et la création par l'audience
du 3 mars de ce nouveau concours spécial
qui permettra assurément une voix
complémentaires permettant la diversité
sur la diversité je me permettrai
d'ajouter un élément il ya plusieurs
champs dans la diversité il y en a un
qui aussi permettrait d'enrichir le
profil des de nos élèves
c'est celui des disciplines le concours
externe est assurément
comment dire conditionnée par la
maîtrise des questions économiques
macroéconomiques ont deux rois c'est
nécessaire c'est intéressant et c'est
utile mais l'évolution des épreuves des
concours permettrait d'ouvrir largement
plus largement par dont le champ des
disciplines permettant alors je ne veux
pas me lancer dans une énumération qui
risquerait de ne pas être exhaustif mais
à d'autres étudiants ayant suivi
d'autres parcours dans d'autres
disciplines de venir enrichir d'abord
les bancs de lynette mais surtout demain
d'avoir auprès des élus des regards
croisés qui ne sont pas simplement issus
de raisonnement juridique aux
économiques sociologiques géographiques
historiques psychologique etc
il n'ya en fait quasiment cache aucune
discipline qui ne peut aider l'action
publique locale ou la servir plutôt la
dernière question a trait à la capacité
que nous avons à faire remonter la la
cohérence ou la perfection de la norme
et il est vrai que quand je disais tout
à l'heure qu'on apprend à nos élèves à
agir en milieu complexe c'est presque un
paradoxe qui pourraient les conduire à
se satisfaire de la complexité et il
faut qu'on garde cette capacité à douter
à remettre en question à ne pas se
satisfaire d'une complexité qui peut les
valoriser ailleurs arrivant à agir dans
cette complexité
donc on a un paradoxe qui invite à plus
d'observations plus de dialogue dans les
territoires entre les départements les
intercoms les communes pour détecter et
les empêchements et une capacité à faire
remonter via pas que lynette loin de là
mais les collectivités leurs
associations d'élus des les incohérences
ou les imperfections beaucoup ce n'est
pas une conclusion bien en écho aux qui
suis extrêmement intéressante qui ont
été posées par les coller vous avez
parlé monsieur gérard de cette
difficulté que nous avons autour de
l'égalité
je pense que nous avons un vrai sujet
parce que
nous parlons pas les uns et les autres
forcément de la même chose et que nous
nous sentons parfois une musique à bas
bruit et nous l'entendons beaucoup plus
en ce moment alors qu'il y ait un projet
4d qui va arriver qui devrait traiter de
la différenciation à bas bruit
s'installe cette petite musique que la
différenciation serait source
d'inégalités et de compétition entre les
territoires et je pense qu'il est
extrêmement important que nous
définissions ce dont nous parlons
il y a une obligation d'égalité de
droits et de libertés personne ne peut
le nier
et personne ne prétend le contraire par
contre pour atteindre cet objectif
d'égalité de de droits d'égalité de
liberté il convient de différencier les
moyens qui permettent d'atteindre cet
objectif d'égalité parce que nous le
savons déjà et dans le droit français ça
existe il ya des dispositions
spécifiques pour les territoires
d'outre-mer
il ya des dispositions spécifiques pour
les communes de montagne pour le
littoral et même au coeur de deux de
l'organisation
une différenciation de dispositions et
d'obligations selon les tailles de
communes je prends un exemple très
simple qui ne peut être contesté par
personne
le nombre de conseillers municipaux
l'obligation de scrutin de liste
ou pas donc ce qui concerne l'ensemble
de nos territoires y compris la
métropole varie selon la taille de la
commune parce que chacun a reconnu avec
pertinence qu'on ne pouvait pas imposer
les mêmes contraintes
selon la taille donc je crois qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à apaiser ce débat nous
l'avons ici au sénat je le dis très
librement et que c'était l'égalité qui
se confondent l'uniformité de moyens
comme la norme je le crois une
contrainte et un empêchement à
l'efficacité de l'action publique et il
faut que nous législateurs nous
partageons ça parce que chacun dit la
ruralité différentes de l'udm de du
lendemain et bien certes c'est tellement
différent qu'il convient que l'on donne
à chacun les mairies qu'il convient à
l'état d'assurer un rôle de péréquation
donc j'y vois là je vous remercie de
m'avoir donné l'occasion de parler de ce
sujet qui est éminemment important je
voudrais faire écho à la la la question
de notre collègue dominique estrosi
sassone sur la diversité des profils qui
arrivent dans les écoles on a cette
particularité je crois dans beaucoup de
filières
parce que on a aussi une sorte
d'assignation à résidence pour les
jeunes qui n'est pas formant forcément
lié uniquement à laon milieu social et à
la culture de ce milieu social parce que
il y a une incapacité à sortir de son
lieu de résidence et de sa communauté il
est très difficile pour quelqu'un qui
habite je vais dire en bretagne centrale
au dans le centre du cantal ou au coeur
du jura d'aller de se projeter dans un
univers d'études en normandie
parce que ça ça bouscule un mode de vie
c'est compliqué donc c'est un sujet
c'est vraiment un sujet qui doit nous
nous intéresser et enfin je vous
remercie très sincèrement des échanges
qui je crois nous éclaire me me conforte
dans l'idée que nous nous avons le même
objectif chacun dans le rôle qui est le
nôtre et qu'il important que nous
parlions et je ferai une conclusion
extrêmement personnel je pense qu'il ne
faut pas sacrifier à l'air d'une
communication de symboles qui font qu'on
sort l'échafaud pour l'ena
parce qu'aujourd'hui on pense que l'ena
résume à elle seule où serait la cause
des maux amériques de la france et
surtout de ses fractures territoriales
et sociales
personnellement je ne pense pas et qu'en
tout cas nous avons en france une
formation de grands serviteurs de l'état
avec des personnes extrêmement
intelligente et que la qualité des
personnels dominé que je pense qu'il
faut le reconnaître vous l'avez dit
monsieur le directeur que les énarques
ne sont pas partout nous avons aussi de
grands corps d'ingénieurs dont on parle
pas beaucoup et je parle d'ingénieurs
technique qui savent nous expliquer que
nous les élus locaux nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre ce que c'est extrêmement
technique vous comprenez voilà donc on
nous noie sous sur la technicité et que
je pense qu'il est extrêmement important
que la france continue à avoir un niveau
d'excellence de formation qui doit
naturellement évolué mais nous avons vu
aussi pendant cette crise sanitaire moi
je ferai pas de comparaison avec les
constats que le général de gaulle à
faire après la guerre mais la crise
sanitaire a quand même montré dans le
domaine sanitaire que nous avions
parfois comment dire des situations
encore une fois ça n'a rien à voir avec
la qualité des personnes n'est
totalement inadapté et décalé par
rapport aux besoins qui étaient les
nôtres et que donc il faut savoir
s'adapter en tout cas essayer vraiment
remercier très chaleureusement et très
sincèrement et nous nous serons très
heureux de poursuivre ce dialogue et je
finirai par une sorte d'anecdotes en
2020 il y eut des élections municipales
et dans mon département d'ille et
vilaine il y avait une femme maire d'une
commune à leurs en l'occurrence rural
qui était une selle mais doom si je puis
dire voilà tu mettrais avec un bon sens
remarquable une capacité d'agir une
ténacité ne lâche jamais rien et cette
femme qui était vice présidente dans son
interco a eu la lourde charge de
mettre en place un pays chacun de nous
ici c'est ce qu'est appel lui la
difficulté d'un culturiste pas et elle
l'a fait d'une manière assez remarquable
assez exceptionnel sur turn 10 et elles
parfois à des avis techniques alors
qu'elle il fallait qu'elles conduisent
aussi politiquement les choses là et je
lui ai dit puisque elle a mis fin à ses
mandats je lui dis que je trouvais
extrêmement intéressant que ddd des élus
locaux de ces nature puisse aussi aller
parfois aux missions nova à l'ena ou
aline aise mais dans des cabinets de
ministères pour expliquer qu' on doit
construire la chose et la capacité à
agir à partir de la finalité de l'action
donc j'aimerais bien aussi qu'on puisse
faire ça merci beaucoup et je crois que
nous sommes à l'heure nous sommes à
l'heure je crois et chers collègues nous
nous en avant-première si je puis dire
nous pouvons vous faire bénéficier de la
communication des résultats de la
consultation nous avons fait que nous
vous nous vous la dre seront bien
volontiers de la consultation nous avons
faite auprès des élus locaux sur nos
cinquante propositions qui fera l'objet
d'une conférence de presse de hausse
mais je vous salue et je reviens à vous
si vous permettez je reconnais
[Musique]